Speaker 1: I've told you before that Secretary
of Transportation Pete Budda, judge, is really,
really good when he appears on right wing
media and when he's responding to his right
wing critics. Well, Pete Budda judge decimated
the homophobic comment of Marjorie Taylor GREENE
from over the weekend. Let's start with
her comment now. I you can check out my
live stream from over the weekend from the Trump
rally I saw Marjorie Taylor GREENE talks about
people to judge without even seeing the clip.
I assumed and I know that sometimes when you
assume you end up maybe made a fool of. But I
assumed that if Marjorie is talking about Pete,
it's probably homophobic. It should be just the
odds are if you've got if I had to bet, I would
say if Marjorie Taylor GREENE is talking about
people to judge, there's probably some homophobic
element to what she says. And indeed, there
was. Indeed, there was. Here is what Marjorie
said about the secretary of transportation.
Speaker 2: More American than the roar of
a V8 engine under the hood of a Ford
Mustang or Chevy Camaro. An incredible
feel of all that horsepower. Wow.
But Democrats like Pete Burgess
want to emasculate the way we drive, right?
Speaker 1: Right. Of course, the gay secretary of
transportation wants to emasculate the way people
drive. Now, what does that mean, emasculate the
way people drive? I don't know. But it probably
has something to do with electric vehicles. Right?
Speaker 2: And for all of you to
rely on electric vehicles after they
shut down your great Michigan auto industry.
Speaker 1: And yeah, by the way, many Michigan
based automakers are making electric vehicles,
making that comment particularly stupid. Let's
go now to Pete Booted Judges response. He appeared
on Fox News with Neil CAVUTO. He was asked about
these comments and his answer is pretty funny.
Speaker 4: For instance, you you're just saying
for this, you've been very consistent with
that. But Representative Marjorie Taylor GREENE,
the Georgia Republican at a rally in
Michigan, said this past weekend that
Mr. Bridges is trying to emasculate the way we
drive by. She goes on to explain by supporting
environmentally friendly transportation.
But what did you think of her wording?
Speaker 1: He's trying to make everybody feminine
by making us drive really cool, fast cars that
you don't need to gas up and can charge in your
driveway. It's really, really feminine of him.
Speaker 4: I literally don't even understand
what that means. I mean, my sense of manhood
is not connected to whether my vehicle is fueled
by gasoline or whether it's fueled by electricity.
Speaker 1: Well, maybe it should be.
Speaker 4: This is a practical value offended
by that term, because even people who, you know,
share her politics didn't share that view. It was
a strange thing to say. You know, to be honest,
there are other members of Congress that I pay
more attention to when I'm thinking about opinions
that really matter or ideas that are going to be
critical to engage with. I do think we need to
zoom out a little, but I don't want to make this
ideological. They want to make it political. We're
talking about something like electric vehicles.
We're talking about a very practical matter.
Speaker 1: Which is imagine taking the issue
of getting off of fossil fuels, at least at the
tailpipe, for the way we drive around and thinking
that the issue really is about how the secretary
of transportation wants to emasculate others.
And implicit in that, of course, of course,
is the fact that people to judge is a gay man.
It's just unbelievable. And I know I've told
the story before, but I'll remind you of it.
I've experienced this. There's something about the
electric cars that really triggers a lot of these
right wingers. And I've described before more than
a couple dozen instances where when I go anywhere
and I park in the parking lot, you know, a grocery
store or not a Starbucks? Of course not. But,
you know, we're at places I really do go. I will
often park, like in the furthest spot from the
front door. And I've always actually done this
just because I just walk more, right? I'll get an
extra walk. I walk more to the front door and then
I walk more back to my car. But also, I am kind
of protective of my electric vehicle and I don't
want to park near people and I like to keep it far
away. And a couple dozen times I will come out
and there is one of these big just gas guzzling
behemoth pickup trucks with a thin blue line
sticker. And once it was with a Confederate flag
parked right next to my car, they're intimidating
me. They're really intimidating me. And also just
on the road, the pickup truck, people with the
with the stickers, the Trump stickers, whatever,
at the at a at a green light. When a red light
goes green, just zooming off and leaving leaving
me in a cloud of black smoke probably cost them
costing them a dollar in gas to it for for that
show of manhood. There's something wrong with
these people. There really is. And Marjorie Taylor
GREENE talking about a V-8 Camaro and Mustang
and electric vehicles, being emasculating is
basically the exact same thing. Will they ever
come around? Yeah, I think eventually they will,
because electric cars are clearly the way things
are going. So I think eventually they will come
around and some right wingers have that that
that F-150 lightning pickup truck, Electric,
is selling pretty damn well. I have to say,